le bilan de la discrimination positive à
sciences po il y a cinq ans la
prestigieuse école décidé d'accueillir
dix sept lycéens issus des zep des
quartiers difficiles sans passer le
concours
l'initiative vous vous en souvenez avait
été très discutée aujourd'hui la
première promotion a terminé sa
scolarité
c'est un succès sur 17 ils ou elles sont
15 à avoir décroché le diplôme
voici l'exemple de l'une d'entre elles
françois jullien pieds-noirs régis mater
elle a rapidement trouvé sa place sur
les bancs de la prestigieuse école il va
est aujourd'hui aux premiers rangs des
élèves issus de milieux modestes pour
recevoir son diplôme il ya cinq ans elle
sortait de banlieue est entrée à
sciences difficile d'intégrer l'élite
on peut parler d'un complexe dans le
sens où on n'avait pas forcément envie
forcément les mêmes références n'avait
pas la même culture les
enfin les mêmes références
bibliographiques et c'est vrai que pour
nous ça a été un challenge d'essayer de
combler ce fossé et quel fossé
il va et sa mère ont fui la guerre en
bosnie il ya 15 ans et se sont installés
à saint thois dans ce lycée classé zep
il va et est une élève brillante en
terminale sciences po frappe à la porte
patron cour a passé un bon dossier
quelques épreuves et elle est reçue est
vrai que c'est quelque part une revanche
mais c'est vrai que si on part une chute
du principe de l'égalité des chances
on peut se dire que c'est pas c'est pas
réservé qu'à quai des personnes qui qui
qui ont fait leurs études dans des
grands lycées parisiens
mais pourquoi pas nous celle qui l'a
poussé c'est madame armand son ancien
prof d'économie on sentait quelqu'un de
curieux quelqu'un qui avait envie de
réussir
othman en jeune cadre dynamique qui va
toucher un salaire qui ne peu près le
trip du mini même cursus même note même
diplôme que les autres comme il va ils
sont 189 sursis 1500 élèves à sciences
po à suivre ce parcours 33 lycées son
partenaire et ce n'est pas fini il ya 10
millions de français qui vivent dans les
banlieues sa cave est étonnant que parmi
ces 10 millions de français
aucun ne soit à l'âge de faire des
études supérieures et qu'aucun ne vienne
à sciences po je pense que l'on peut
qualifier parcours de notre parcours est
ici et je travaille il va devrait faire
une belle carrière dans l'audit en
entreprise à la rentrée d'autres élèves
issus de milieux modestes vont prendre
sa place sur les bancs de sciences po